[Music]
welcome back
to off the record what are we talking
about
why anthony what what's up
with man jewelry or moolry as they call
it
what's maury i've never heard that
you never heard of that i've never heard
him like what he got off yeah how do you
have the confidence
to wear moory like you got rings on you
get all kinds of accoutrement
accoutrements i like man jewelry i just
got
uncomfortable you why oh because like
you know you got to put it on and then
you know like i think
as guys were lazy first that's true and
then style second
facts except for anthony i think
anthony's style first lazy second right
very style first same time is that right
he's more balanced maybe you were like a
maybe he's a 50 50
lazy in style and maybe we're like a 90
10. i think we are i've never worn rings
until my wedding ring
you're like a you're like a but you got
70 30.
i usually will do one chain i don't know
why i forgot to put on today
one chain and then i will always if i
don't have my earrings in when i leave
the house i feel naked
so today you're a 60 lazy 40 style
yes because i would put you in the same
boat as uh anthony here you're a 50 50.
you don't have earrings but you have the
ring rings
i've never seen him without the
accoutrement i've seen you without a
plenty
that's the only difference seeing them
naked at late night stuff i mean you
have yet to brush that like area
yeah i've seen the intimate parts of
your bank account you have yeah
and that's what you've seen naked baby
ain't no accoutrement there yeah that's
a
man jewelry no but i remember because i
you know
growing up you see dudes like i remember
when harrison ford had
like an earring on i was like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] harrison [ __ ] forward
like got an earring that's han solo bro
that's a handsome look
guys with earrings didn't you go oh i
want one too
or did you go you're looking you're kind
of gay bro
i was just like runner like michael
jordan or michael jordan jordan
yeah jordan you know what's back now in
style for dudes is um
a dangly a little dangly earring is that
yeah i feel like you got to be a certain
type of dude to pull that off
like a little maybe like a little dangly
like cross or something like little
upside down pyramids i wanted a a
feather
but i feel like i would be appropriating
native americans so i didn't do it
it's gotta be an asian feather from like
a phoenix oh i never thought of that
so if i get an asian bird or a goose i
just get a japanese goose yeah
oh dude okay you don't even have to talk
all right
they literally wrote the constitution
with feathers i got you on this one
you're good all right all right all
right i um when i was growing up my dad
was completely against tattoos and
piercings but he was more against
uh tattoos and so one day he went to
thailand for like
a month he was gone i was like 15. no
maybe i was like 17.
he left thailand for a month and then so
i went and got pierced and then when he
was gone my mom thought it was cute
and then my dad came back we picked him
up from the airport and he walked to the
house he saw my earrings he was like
just walked off did you think it was
gang culture he didn't i don't know he
didn't like ground you or beat your ass
he didn't talk to me for like a week and
then he was fine but he also just came
out with a new backpack for
thailand tigers and [ __ ] did he ever
tell you
why it was bad or he didn't like it you
know i never even asked
him right now but literally like two
days ago i i texted my dad i was like
hey dad can you can you write out
um chant the roxy for me and ty so i can
get it tatted and he just sent me like
an angry emoji he was like no
tattoos that's because i think a lot of
our parents generation thinks it's all
gang-related stuff so he's like
i don't want my son to be tainted into
the gang world it probably was game
related back then
yeah to them probably but i mean you
know it's a whole new generation dad i
mean your son does videos and raps on
the internet you know it's like what do
you care about a tattoo
well they i they act like the tattoos
forever but making videos is apparently
forever too
that's both what if you ask your mom how
to spell
or how to write it and ty oh she would
probably do it for me is there
different ways to write it like in thai
is that why because like in japanese um
it can sound the same but the characters
could be different depending on
what it means the style of kanji yeah no
um tai
is high alphabet is like you know each
symbol is its own specific like
sound yeah yeah yeah is it phonetic it's
phonetic oh okay you know my dad would
be down for though that he's mentioned
to me is the
traditional monk like oh wow he's like
if you get that then i'm cool with that
and i want to
but the result looks the same yeah what
the [ __ ] is just saying that because you
think she won't
get that one i'm so down for that no but
the monk ones are like
patterns because it's spiritual it's
patterns and like you know depending
like they can do like little like
there's like like tigers and like
different things that i've seen
you know why do you feel like he's gonna
be more okay with that i'm sure i can
make
you know assumptions but i'm just
wondering man i don't know i feel like
um
i don't know it's so it's so crazy that
you never asked that that'll be the
first thing i ask i'm like i'll be like
why
like why why are you against it he just
gave the answer the reason why is
because he thinks all this shit's [ __ ]
yeah exactly that thinks you gotta do it
the real way you gotta [ __ ] have a
[ __ ] guy
i guess so yeah do the real tattoo
machine he was like if you do that then
then i'll be cool with that i'm like all
right dad next time i'm going to
thailand i'm doing that [ __ ]
he thinks tattoo guns are the [ __ ]
[ __ ] name
tattoo goes for a [ __ ] bro that's [ __ ]
that's crazy yeah that is pretty
hardcore though i have a [ __ ] needle
just hammering away into your stance
i don't know if i can handle that how
was this situation was that a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um what was your most painful tattoo uh
probably around the armpit
area and then up here like close to the
neck it hurts like crazy you got to have
[ __ ] plastic bags around you like
ziplock all this [ __ ]
uh well this part this upper part this
was like maybe like
uh like 35 hours this might have been
like 28 hours how many do you have
i guess i don't know one two or three in
my lake it's not even that good for 35
hours
that's all you got ain't even no colors
on that [ __ ]
what is it what even is it there's a
bunch of lies
[ __ ] lines and shading [ __ ] like
leaves i think i don't even know dude
we're in kyoto and in japan like it's
still
like pretty serious if you have a tattoo
right because only
the mob wears it and then if they're
exposing it that means like
they're out to go into a rumble or
something is going to happen right
but uh him and ant you know they're both
sleeved up
they're walking down these old people
they saw and they cleared the [ __ ]
road like it was
last like last samurai you know that why
are marching and [ __ ]
and then all the peasants go to the side
and put their head down like that
damn because when you can't really get
in the way
of the mob walking through or else you
know you're gonna get [ __ ] up
king tom cruise walking through in a
samurai yeah
let's be honest can we bow to him please
tom cruise an epic performance in an
epic film
one of my favorites i love that movie
[Laughter]
if you ever see a picture of me by the
way in a samurai costume
online i am in fact tom cruise from the
last samurai [ __ ]
that's the context oh my god
too many mines how many tattoos you got
huh me yeah yeah
i only got a bunch of little ones from
different stories one two
three what's the palm tree five six
six why you got a palm tree it's when i
was in hawaii
i got like a little hawaiian background
that's my family and i was just like
this is chill as [ __ ]
and we all got tattoos together and i
was like i'm gonna get a palm tree
because
damn it reminds me of hawaii because
when i look at that i'm like hawaii i
gotta do a
hawaii one too it's probably gonna be
like a spam musubi
probably yeah yeah that makes sense i'll
play the loco moco you know
a girl going like this with a papaya
half open and she's playing with it like
that yeah
that'll be pretty cool oh they're strong
that's hella strong what's this what's
that sign over there gemini
oh you're a gemini i am a gemini
switching size like a gemini
oh [ __ ] give me that one of the
coolest that's gonna be his excuse for
everything
well i'm sorry i'm a gemini you know
what's a good man when it comes to
tattoos like this i never get like hate
for it
but other geminis who are about it for
whatever reason always coming up and
then
the funniest conversations always happen
you know what i mean i was like are you
a gemini
it's like obviously you know this i was
wearing [ __ ] crypto merch
and and i was helping my friend move and
i got
stuck in a conversation with guys like
yo dude how do i access
the the dark web and i was like bro i
have no [ __ ] idea
this cat really thought because i had a
wikileaks shirt on
and i had my crypt i had a v chain hat
on i think it's totally fair for him to
assume though
i understand but he really did think
that like i knew how to access the dark
web and to get him mushrooms on the dark
web i'm not even kidding it sounds like
a bit
i'm not kidding this guy cornered me you
idiot you don't get him on the dark web
he's my friend's number though yeah yeah
he's like i know that some people use
the dark web for like hitman stuff and
that's not really what i'm about brother
and i was like that guy doesn't have a
connect for mushrooms no he didn't in
the dark web
your brother i don't do any drugs at all
and i could literally find mushrooms in
like an hour if you don't need a
mushroom that's like three guys
mushroom king over here dude i don't
think he wanted those mushrooms
he's like a shiitake i don't need this
but i'm like am i dressing wrong what am
i doing wrong here
that's not my guy though he found the
right guy well dude i'm like if you want
to
you know one thing about like this
though in his mind he's like looking
around he is he doesn't have a lot of
options he looks at you and he's like
that guy's suss hey everybody today's
video is brought to you by
upstart and thank god upstart came into
my life
hmm why so you know how we know that
kryptos down these days right
oh i know and i invested a lot this year
oh we know but i also like to play with
my toys
and i just got a new truck to take the
family out with and you know me i don't
like to leave my vehicle stock
i like to put stuff on it but because i
have all my money invested in crypto and
i know it's just a timing issue it's not
that i don't have the money or not gonna
get the money
it's right now i have a really good deal
on some parts
and i don't wanna lose it because parts
are hard to get
father's day is coming up they got 15 20
off on a lot of websites so i want to
save some money
so guess what i got upstart and i'm
gonna be able to get my full suspension
and my exhaust and i'm gonna get the
money in the next day
that's crazy quick because you know
what's pretty awesome about upstart
is they know that you're more than just
your credit score
and they give you up to like 50
000 that's pretty
that's pretty nice that's really good
that's like a whole car especially how
fast they
get you the money too the next day and
they use other things like do you got a
job
or do you got a degree and they gather
all this information and decide
if they should lend you some money or
not so go check out upstart.com
for yourself to see if it can help you
lower your monthly payments or if you're
in a pinch
or if you got investment opportunity
here's another way to take a small loan
now that's not just based off your
credit score it's based off your income
and all the other information that you
put on your application
go to upstart.com off the record that's
upstart.com
off the record to see if upstart can
help you
plus that guy sounds like a [ __ ]
dweeb bro yeah drugs
yeah he was dating he was day drunk
he's wearing a wire that guy sure i'm
day drunk you're taking him too
um i used to go to school with this girl
that wore like her sign around her neck
and [ __ ] like she was super into it
right
and then she was looking at me one day
she was like you're pisces aren't you
and i was like yeah how'd you know and
she goes she goes
you look like one it's like that's it oh
that's it
what the [ __ ] does that mean that like
apparently
people look like their sign they'll be
like aries has a
you know this kind of shaped face or
whatever whatever like they have a
profile based off of your [ __ ]
horoscope of
what your physical characteristics are
gonna be like
she didn't tell you she asked like 14
other people the same
you gotta know you gotta be right
eventually
yeah but like apparently i look like a
pisces to be honest i'm not even
super into uh horoscope
yeah science so what was that tattoo
what is it what's the meaning of it
super into it yeah but i always enjoy
i always enjoy that feeling because i
feel like any time people look
this is some weird ass human experience
i think everybody can like understand
this
when you like read a fortune cookie or
when you read a horoscope when you get
your [ __ ] tarot cards read or
whatever the [ __ ]
it doesn't matter what comes out you
like start to
actualize your like understanding
relativity in that moment to that thing
and there's some sort of weird
subconscious behavior that we all have
as human beings that like
when it comes to things in this i don't
know the spectrum of life
there's this there's this fun to it to
that i i don't know i just enjoyed the
idea where i don't know [ __ ] about
geminis and horoscopes but anytime
somebody's like you're a gemini because
of this i'm like
[ __ ] yeah not forget it that's crazy i'm
the opposite i immediately deny it like
i read something i'm like what the [ __ ]
what's your sign
that's so scorpio of you dog
this guy you know you know what i do and
this is so like just this is so annoying
on me
whenever someone i know tweets some [ __ ]
like that about how stupid zodiac signs
are
i will look i will go out of my way to
find their birthday
and i look up their sign i'm like that's
such
a capricorn thing
like everybody over there yeah it
doesn't matter if it fits it usually
works [ __ ] hurts them in the heart
even if they don't say anything
let me tell you right now it hurts yeah
not gonna lie like i'm i'm the same like
i'm not super into that [ __ ] i don't
know
anything really outside of my own sign
and and this like girl i used to date
who i was like oh okay never again
but uh but like
she she was a [ __ ] leo dude
not compatible with pisces at all dogs
leos without leos
because like prices are laid back and
leo lying [ __ ] super hard-headed you
feel me but
so i never dated a leo but we're
supposed to be compatible hey yo my
wife's a leo bro
oh okay i don't know
[Laughter]
i'm supposed to be compatible with
sagittarius and leo
and the god of war georgina argina is a
leo
female oh just for context oh god
my wife's a leo is she she's not that
bad though she don't feel like gina at
all
not a gina then that means she might be
like a leo who's on the cusp
i think she's a customer that's why they
got the [ __ ] rising and dying signs
now yeah
i know i gotta flip it so not gonna lie
like when
when me and chia were trying to conceive
i was like yo
if we could have a pisces baby like me
because i like i think i'm
really cool that would be dope let's
have a little chill baby like me right
even though i don't 100 believe into it
but i i kind of do i'm like let's try to
have a pisces baby so we started busting
nuts
according to like the timeline of having
a pisces baby
and and it and everything was good right
and but then you did the retrograde
this little girl came out early and
she's old
and she's and she's a [ __ ] aquarius
messed up
nobody wants those
i think she'll be chill as well oh it's
both water sign [ __ ] i don't know
exactly this was
a water sign but i think it's chill
what's chia what's her dream
she's capricorn um i don't know no
capricorns
capricorns are i don't know what the
means not gonna lie like okay everything
i read about capricorns is very chill
like organized
needs to know needs to plan things out
that sounds like a lot of girls
this girl yeah i mean is even the most
chaotic girls be organized
gina darling she's not organized
no and by the way nikki nikki limo green
not organized until recently very odd i
think it's mercury retrograde
changing your personality that's the
explanation i think she'll be
disappointed
organization more of a trait than an
inherit like a
learned trait then you're born a
planetary alignment bro
gravity from the [ __ ] planets you
[ __ ] eat stars bro
my mom's been trying to get me organized
since i was a little boy and it never
worked dog
see that's why you can't even wash the
socks dude
yeah man joe what are you saying that's
crazy crackpot you know what's funny
about
so areas of them to say something
you know why it feels good to uh do the
horoscopes and you know that you're
right
it's called a confirmation bias my
friend
what's your sign and then when you're
i'm like
i'm an aries what's this that's some
areas just to say bro got you i'm
aquarius huh
oh no you're not that's a lie i know i
have my area
there's liars dog carries me caught in a
lie
aquarius classic aries you know you know
why it's also pretty cool though
is like um like i don't believe this
[ __ ] either but
what i like is uh things that can snappy
snap me out of a mindset that i don't
want to be in
so when you're in when you're reading
horoscope [ __ ] right you can
it's like the same thing with
manifestation is whatever
your mind is thinking about all the time
it can
it's it'll be more likely that you'll
get that right so like
if you keep thinking about iphones
you're probably going to buy an iphone
like if you keep thinking about oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] well
for some people they still never get it
but you know mostly yeah or like or like
if you think about
but when you think about a red car and
all you've seen is red cars on the
street that's the bias right
yeah so if you read your [ __ ] fortune
cookie right and they're like you're
going to be lucky and you go oh i'm
gonna be lucky i'm gonna be lucky
you're gonna be blind to all the shitty
things that happen to you but you're
gonna be like
i'm gonna feel lucky you'll find the
luckiest thing that you have yeah like
my car broke down to the other day and
i'm like i'm so lucky that i had uh
traffic during that time 100
because hey man if it was going fast on
the highway
that would have been the unlucky thing
or i'm lucky because someone pulled over
and offered me gas
that's facts bro cause i mean look even
like when you want to call somebody like
people would say being optimistic is
kind of like delusional right if like oh
but everything is delusion bro yeah
all right it's what you choose to
believe completely
because because like for me i'm like
what time are you huh
that's true i'm always like bro like yo
i'm like the universe is looking out for
me i'm [ __ ] blessed so it's like i'm
always kind of trying to look at the
good side right so it's like even like i
try to
when little good [ __ ] happens i'm like
bro [ __ ] blessing from the universe
you know what i'm saying but it's like
if you're not
in that mindset and you're not paying
attention to the good [ __ ] that's
happening to you it's kind of
easy to overlook that and only pay
attention to the whack [ __ ] that's
happening right you know what blows my
mind is like
people that are negative they'll be like
oh i'm just being
real like get go go get down to reality
i'm like
there's millions of ways you could look
at this but you choose to see the
shittiest parts of
it and then you're saying that that's
more realer than my perspective well
look i used to be skeptical as [ __ ]
about mercury retrograde
i gotta say recently me and nikki we got
an above-ground jacuzzi it's called a
coleman jacuzzi
now this thing is working great when we
first got it two months ago
no problems mercury retrograde hits
how many times does it hit a year
apparently it's like every other month
what the [ __ ] that's called the period
that's
synced up with the period it's synced up
for sure but
our our inflatable jacuzzi is going
great now all of a sudden it's having
all kinds of error
problems error messages all kinds of
issues it's not because it's overused
it's not because it's overused it's not
because it's an inflatable jacuzzi i can
read your minds
it's not because it's really hot it's
not because it's really hot it's because
of mercury [ __ ] retrograde damn
wait till that shit's over and the hot
tub starts working that's why my car
broke down two days ago
mercury it's not the alternator it's not
over yet it's a [ __ ] mercury
retrograde that son of a [ __ ] that's
why crypto's going down
mercury
man
that's why i had to re-delegate to my
different node
[Laughter]
you guys everybody knows what that is
we're all on game y'all
mercury [ __ ] retrograde man what's
your sign again
i'm a virgo you're a virgo
what about you nick i'm a libra dude we
got every
[ __ ] kind just like no wonder i love
you guys
i remind you of your wife your full
representation here how many more
how many do they have she's the leader
of two hot dogs what are you doing
might be twelve so we got half in the
room damn
every different representation what
about what about the the chinese zodiac
you guys fought oh
[ __ ] man i'm a lawsuit dude
i'm a rat i'm a tiger as well tiger baby
are you the same year 86 yeah
that was the tigers these are my sisters
here that's how that's
what are you a tiger [ __ ] chicken i'm
a monkey bro [ __ ] chicken that's
it 92. yeah i'm a mouse me too all right
you're a rat
he's trying to he's trying to spice it
up he's out of my mouth yo the the
chinese [ __ ] gets kind of when you start
to really dig into the specifics when
you like i was looking i was just kind
of i was on a shoot one time and someone
had a chinese zodiac book
and i was like let me just go through my
there's only 12 pages no dog
a [ __ ]
then you go through a dog and you go
through like your specific [ __ ] and i'm
like wow this is very
specific uh and it was kind of like i
was like wow this is like
the first thing that says that american
[ __ ] is fake
chinese at the real [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
what i agree
your name's tim your dick is three
inches long i was like yeah
you know what you do when i was like
trying to talk to a girl right about oh
what's your sign
and if it didn't match for the american
one or the the
the the the convenient one yeah like
whatever it's like oh damn we're like
the worst match
i go to the chinese one and if that
match i'll be like check
this out though the chinese one we're
like perfect dude but the american one
i used to do same [ __ ] on dates where i
would ask them what their sign was and
i'd be like let's look let's google if
we're compatible
and then you're just kind of sitting
there let's check the chinese one
the good [ __ ] cuz you know they read
good and bad yeah you skip the bad [ __ ]
right
you're trying to i'm trying to get laid
tonight what do i say
yeah but there's a compatibility meter
and they'll tell you how [ __ ]
compatible you are
[Music]
so
[Music]